yours of everybody this procedure man
Luigi with another portal nzp sequel
video and some pretty exciting news now
there's been a quick update or a hotfix
to borderlands the pre-sequel that lets
you grind more now you can grind shields
you can grind I believe class mods you
can buy grind grenade mods all to get
better of that version just like you can
do with guns and you can see there I had
three legendary shields you can grind
three of any of these accessories into a
new legendary accessory now be warned
that you cannot moonstone grind in these
because I guess they do not have
moonshine of moonshine effects that they
can apply to them yet so you could you
have the opportunity to get them purple
even if you're grinding three
legendaries but this is some really
exciting news since prior to this we
couldn't grind shields or oz kits or
grenade mods and it really took away
from the grinding experience so now you
can see I did it with a oz kit as well
and I had not done this with class mods
or grenade mods a grenade mom's I'm like
97% sure it works
however class mods I'm little wary to
say if it works or not you can see here
I'm probably gonna get a purple shield
and that's just an example of how you
might not get a legendary so be warned
now this there's an also a possible
update to guns I cannot recall if this
hat this is new but I believe it's new
you can grind three legendary weapons
and I'll give you a new legendary weapon
however this does not take away from the
fact that you can still grind to
legendaries and a purple and you will
get a new legendary you're the chance of
getting new legendary almost confirmed
if you grind it with moonstone and all
of the other um normal grinding rules
still do apply in terms of you can't
grind uniques you can't grind different
colors of things you can't grind guns
with non guns you can't grind shield
with non shield such and so forth but I
do think this is really cool you saw
there I put in three legendary weapons
and I got a new legend
weapon so this is kind of interesting I
would kind of hope that they would have
taken out the two legendaries and a
purple and just gone so only with the
three legendaries since it obviously is
gonna work for the shield's since you
can only do it with the shield
no up actually grinding with two
legendary shields and a purple ship I
believe does not work so that I would
think that should apply to guns but it
doesn't so yeah hope you enjoyed this
quick little video I hope you guys can
go grind your stuff this is really cool
and exciting to me personally because it
can't it's a lot more grinding of the
opportunities so I hope you guys enjoyed
the video if you have make sure you
check out my channel for more borderline
super sequel stuff and we'll see you all
later pizza